Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Vamos a escuchar el audio de un grupo
de mujeres conversando por WhatsApp
sobre los sonidos y las letras.
“¿Practicaste, Nati? Yo no te escuché.
A ver, mandá un audio del abecedario acá,
así escuchamos todas, nuestras compañeras,
y te ponemos puntaje”.
“Y bueno, Sonia, dale, te toca, a mí me
dio vergüenza, pero bueno,
demostré que estaba haciendo
las letras, el sonido.
Te toca a vos, Sonia”.
“Y si porque para nosotros era difícil;
hasta que la agarremos la mano.
Un par de letra me acordé y otras como
que se me borraron, ¿viste?
Pero ahora, escuchando los audios,
las voy a practicar”.
“Después la que me sale bien es esta,
escuchá.
Por si no te diste cuenta, era la hache,
porque ¿viste que la hache es muda?”
Las que acabamos de escuchar son mujeres
en situación de mucha vulnerabilidad,
que una noche desde sus casas
se pusieron a jugar
con los sonidos y las letras.
Estas mujeres se estaban formando
como alfabetizadores comunitarias
porque en sus barrios hay muchos chicos
de 8, 10, 14 años
que no saben leer y escribir
a pesar de estar escolarizados.
Veamos algunos ejemplos.
Javier tiene 9 años.
Está en tercer grado y la única palabra
que pudo escribir completa es mamá.
Alejandro,
tiene 10 años, está en quinto grado,
y solo pudo poner algunas vocales
de las palabras que le propusimos.
Florencia tiene 13.
También está en quinto grado.
En algunas palabras pudo poner dos letras,
en otras una sola.
Cuesta imaginar lo que siente
un chico de 10 años, una chica de 13
que no saben leer y escribir.
¿Se acuerdan cuando aprendieron
a leer y escribir?
Yo me acuerdo.
Me acuerdo de ese instante increíble en
que entendí cómo funcionaba la escritura.
Y me acuerdo de la sensación de que ahora
yo también conocía un secreto
que hasta hace unos minutos
era solo de los grandes.
Miles de chicos y chicas
nunca tienen esta experiencia.
Y no saben el sufrimiento que les produce.
Porque esto no pasa solamente
en unos pocos barrios.
Mucha gente no lo sabe, pero en nuestro
país hay miles de chicos y chicas
de los sectores más pobres
que terminan la escuela primaria
sin saber leer y escribir.
Cuesta creerlo, ¿no?
Todos pensamos que el tema
de la alfabetización está resuelto.
Bueno, no es así.
No tenemos datos, pero se estima
que hasta un 10 % de los chicos
y las chicas en contextos de pobreza
egresa de la escuela primaria
en esta situación.
Es un drama invisible.
Es una tragedia silenciosa.
Pero hasta acá las malas noticias.
La buena noticia es que hay mucho que
podemos hacer por la alfabetización,
fundamentalmente porque no hay nada que
esté mal en los chicos y en las chicas.
Son entusiastas, son inteligentes,
tienen un enorme potencial.
Depende de nosotros
que puedan desarrollarlo.
Después de muchos años de trabajar como
maestra y como educadora comunitaria
y después como investigadora
en temas de lectura y escritura,
hace 10 años desarrollé la propuesta DALE!
Un programa para enseñar
a leer y a escribir
a chicos que llevan muchos años
en la escuela sin haber aprendido.
DALE significa Derecho a Aprender
a Leer y a Escribir,
porque leer y escribir es un derecho.
DALE me permitió conocer
a nenas como Juana.
Juana tenía 9 años, estaba repitiendo
tercer grado, era simpatiquísima, vivaz,
entusiasta, pero no sabía leer y escribir.
Así escribió cuando le pedí
que pusiera algunas palabras.
Ese es su intento por escribir mamá,
pelota, oso, mesa y pomelo.
No pudo, la escuela a la que iba Juana
estaba implementando,
al igual que otras escuelas de la zona,
la propuesta DALE.
Entonces una docente trabajó con ella
durante más o menos tres meses,
en una cantidad de encuentros
que en total no sumaron más
de 8 horas de trabajo.
Así escribía Juana después de eso.
Claramente,
esta nena no tenía una dificultad
de aprendizaje, porque ningún chico,
ninguna chica con
dificultades de aprendizaje
avanza a esta velocidad
en esa cantidad de tiempo.
Ella lo que necesitaba era que
le enseñaran de otra manera.
Y está muy lejos de ser
la única en avanzar así.
Tenemos datos de la evaluación de cientos
de chicos y chicas de 8 a 14 años
que no sabían leer y escribir y después
de tres meses el 80 % había arrancado.
¿Se dan cuenta de lo que estamos diciendo?
Estamos diciendo que miles
de chicos y chicas
crecen durante años
sin saber leer y escribir
y que esto podría
resolverse en tres meses.
¿Qué hacemos en DALE?
En darle un adulto trabaja
con un niño o una niña
2 veces por semana durante 20 minutos.
Lo primero que hacemos en cada encuentro
es tratar de conocerlos, de reconocerlos.
Les pedimos que nos cuenten algo de
su vida, algo que les gusta, qué hacen,
qué les interesa, qué los alegra,
qué los entristece.
Y después les ayudamos a escribir
algo de lo que nos contaron,
aunque sea una oración muy cortita.
Porque ¿qué mejor manera
de aprender a escribir
que escribiendo la propia historia?
En el segundo momento entramos de lleno
en la escritura de palabras.
Jugamos con los sonidos de las letras,
como hacía las mujeres al principio,
claro, pero hacemos algo más,
hacemos algo que la neurociencia
y la psicolingüística nos mostraron
que es el mejor camino.
Enseñamos a los chicos a escucharse,
a prestar atención a sus propias palabras.
¿Vieron alguna vez un chico,
una chica que está aprendiendo
a escribir y quiere escribir?
No sé, dado, y empieza d-a-d...
Y nosotros decimos
está buscando las letras.
No, no está buscando las letras.
Está tratando de darse cuenta cuáles
son los sonidos que forman esa sílaba
que está repitiendo.
Cuando un músico escucha una melodía,
si la quiere reproducir,
tiene que reconocer cada uno
de los sonidos que la forman.
Para escribir palabras,
tenemos que reconocer cada uno
de los sonidos que forman esa palabra.
Después vienen las letras.
Reconocer los sonidos que forman
las palabras es una habilidad
que se llama conciencia fonológica.
Y hoy sabemos que es la llave del
aprendizaje de la lectura y la escritura.
Así de simple.
En el tercer momento de cada encuentro
de DALE leemos.
Al principio, la docente
le lee a los chicos.
Les lee cuentos, después
leen juntos, después los chicos
van aprendiendo a leer
y leen por sí mismos.
Lo primero
qué vemos en los chicos
que participan en DALE
es cómo cambia su confianza en sí mismos.
Llegan tímidos, casi avergonzados.
Y se van orgullosos.
Dediqué toda mi vida a buscar la mejor
manera de enseñarle a leer y a escribir
a los chicos en estas situaciones.
Desde hace 10 años, DALE me permitió,
junto al equipo, formar alfabetizadores
y alfabetizadores en muchas
provincias del país.
Trabajamos con escuelas, trabajamos
con maestros y maestras.
Miles de chicos y de chicas aprendieron.
Pero quedan miles más.
Hemos empezado a trabajar con ministerios
de educación de algunas provincias
para que ningún chico, ninguna chica,
termine segundo grado
sin saber leer y escribir
y para que los chicos que ya son grandes
y que no aprendieron, puedan aprender.
Pero ahora la pandemia nos
planteó un nuevo desafío.
En estos dos años son muchos más los
chicos y las chicas que no aprendieron.
También nos trajo nuevas maneras de
comunicarnos, de conectarnos y entonces
nos preguntamos si sería posible llevar
DALE al formato virtual.
Y ¿cuál sería la mejor manera
de hacer esto?
Porque esto nos permitiría ser más y
llegar a muchos más chicos y chicas.
Así que con esta idea en mente,
junto con TEDxRíodelaPlata,
estamos haciendo una primera experiencia.
Estamos formando a jóvenes que
participaron de los clubes tener
como alfabetizadores para
que implementen DALE
con chicos y chicas que
desde sus centros comunitarios
se conectan a través de una tablet.
Por ahora estamos aprendiendo,
estamos experimentando.
Hace algunos años,
en un cerro en el noroeste argentino,
trabajé con una nena que no había
aprendido a leer y escribir.
Le ayudé a escribir su primer
oración a partir de algo
que ella me había contado.
Y cuando terminamos de escribir
la nena me miró de una manera tan especial
que durante días me pregunté
qué era eso que yo había visto
en su mirada.
Hasta que entendí.
Lo que había en la mirada
de la nena era esperanza.
La nena parecía preguntarme:
¿De verdad pensás
que voy a poder yo también?
Miles de maestras, de maestros, de
educadores y educadoras comunitarios
trabajamos para que esta esperanza
se vuelva realidad.
Y yo sueño con que seamos muchas,
muchos, muchísimos más.
Muchas gracias.